The interesting thing is that we can do this
for all parts of the program.
For every single function in the program,
we can look up the changes and find out which problems
were addressed in that specific file or in that specific function.
What we get this way is a defect count for every single location.
That is, the number of problems that have been fixed in that very file or function.
In 2007, my students and I built such a tool that would create
such a mapping from the version databases and problem databases
of open source programs.
For instance, we would apply this on Firefox--the web browser--
in order to find out where the most defects were.
More specifically, we would be looking at security defects--
that is, problems that relate to security issues.
What we would get is precisely the location where the most
security bugs would be.